hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to sorry I
don't look my best but seeing how we did
the top 11 best movie sequels of all
time it only figures to do the top 11
worse and guess what
please assume or the top 11 so we had to
do the absolute worst and I got ready in
some respects the sequels are very
difficult to do trying to capture the
magic of something people clearly liked
and trying to make lightning strike
twice while also taking the idea to a
new level but many sequels not only fail
at that but pour salt in the wound of
annoyance there's clearly more bad
sequels out there than good sequel so
let's go ahead and determine how these
will be judged we're going to be
comparing how much the sequel went down
the previous film or film it also has to
have been shown in theaters and come
from a series that started with problems
we knew nothing could improve Twilight
so why would it be a letdown at the
seagulls were bad these are the films
that could have been a contender but
instead turned into a cont wonder what's
that
that was bad and onto something popular
you up well then I got you in just the
right mood we're going to look at the
top of Leavenworth movie continuations @
y top 11 because Tom 80 would go too
long this is the top 11 work sequel
[Music]
number eleven Godfather Part three I'm
putting this solo on the list because it
is still unconfident we may fill it
still is for Coppola it does have a
memorable line or two
okay just one just when I thought I was
out okay
and if it was released on its own it
just be seen as an ordinary bad flick
not one of the worst but seeing how this
is coming off of the heels of not one
but who of what many consider the
greatest films ever made this flick was
painful to sit through it went from
subtle complex powerful storytelling to
over-the-top acting over-the-top writing
and even over-the-top kill when someone
died in these movies it felt real
chilling often disturbingly quiet hear a
helicopter tries to take out people like
a fast and furious movie we're gonna
asshole whining about lucky coat yeah
you're not lasted long in the Mafia
world
the writing get needlessly complicated
involving incest
controlling the vatican bank even ties
to the friggin Pope come on it I know
the Mafia is big but there was a
godfather part four they probably go
after the world neck like dr. evil and
yeah let's talk about that elephant in
the room Sofia Coppola Francis had a
tendency of sneaking his daughter into
it films but here he gave her a starring
role and I really wanted I'm here little
cousin I love my thank God she can
direct in fact here's a visual
representation of her trying to have an
acting career now everybody talks like
how people think gangsters talk in
mobster movies I say to all of you I
have been treated this day with no
respect you will not give I'll take and
it doesn't help that the lines are
written just as bad against the Esquire
magazine award the best-dressed case
it's your first cousin denizens this was
also at a point when Cochino decided it
was better to not be but she no but
instead a really yelling impression of
Pacino I spent my life protecting my
family how the high and mighty fall this
was a letdown that equally any of us
[Music]
number 10 Blair with two book of shadows
let's debate whether or not the first
Blair Witch Project is a legitimately
good movie
some say it's subtle and inspired others
say it's just shaky-cam and screaming
regardless it start a whole new genre of
horror on virtually no budget and it
changed the course of how many horror
films are made of as many disagreements
on the first one everyone agrees Blair
Witch 2 is shit with laughable
characters bizarre editing ridiculous
visuals and an uncountable amount of
storylines that go nowhere like none of
them even the intro it opens up for time
it's like the endings the clue is in
multiple choice do I get to choose which
one we open up with it doesn't matter
because none of them are explained
there's a miscarriage dead owl shredded
paper snowing on people ghost girls
ghosts dogs
crash cars videos playback words that
reveal orgies recordings of murders that
may or may not have happened the way was
recorded and not one solitary incident
is ever given a reason why or how this
movie throws every pointless plot thread
at us all except for what the Book of
Shadows
yeah there's no book of shadows in it
the title of the guide be a movie in
facts come to think about it how we have
a know there's a Blair Witch it's
amazing how not only does this not work
as a sequel connecting in almost no way
to the first except by acknowledging
that there was a first they wanna go to
the same site where it took place but it
in no way holds up as a standalone film
either its mind bogglingly insane and
not in an interesting or scary way just
and in the same way
who knows what anyone was thinking let
me put this craziness together they may
have kept the camera still but outside
of that it's just a Blair mess
[Music]
number nine the Transformers sequels it
doesn't matter which one they're all
exactly the same now don't get me wrong
the first film is a stupid piece of
action fluff but as action flop went it
could be kinda fun Michael Bay got a ton
of death threats after he was announced
as the director of the first film but
after a premiere that audiences saw cool
robots fighting a couple of laps and
even the original voice of Optimus Prime
in there people seem to like would
almost seem like a satire of the BEI
movies while still being a bay movie the
death threats seem to stop they started
right back up again with transformers
two three four and you know it's just
survived in there even though hasn't
come out yet many say that they insult
what the original transformers were
trying to do others say they're racist
others say they're sexist others say
they're whatever other is serious out
there others say it's loud obnoxious and
dumb but truth be told a lot of that
doesn't bother me as much what bothers
me the most is that they're boring
they are so boring with the first film
Singh giant robot fight each other on
such a grand scale on the desert and the
city was never really seen at least did
that size and effort in the second film
like just fight in the desert okay we
saw that and in the third film they find
the city okay we saw that and then a
fourth film me fighting another thing to
the exact mukbang some mel piece of shit
comes along to fuck things up there's
some bullshit about his humanity worth
it to make it think it's trying to be
deep some dumbass joke to the time
they'll be baited really fast and then
it does everything in its power to make
explosions mean nothing Christ
I remember when explosions were such a
cool thing a giant ball of fire how
destructive yet amazing and now it's
like we're watching a bucket of paint
thank you Michael Bay explosions are now
a bucket of paint to me you sucked out
all the excitement with nothing new ever
added and seems literally recycle like
he just played the exacting clips which
should be cool and thrilling is just
white
always in fact that's a perfect nickname
for the director white noise with no
impacts no thought no good humor and no
interest in doing anything different
these films ask the questions Americans
sadly have to ask a lot if it makes
money why change it number eight x-men
origins Wolverine its reason a point of
having x-men origins at the beginning I
mean they never made another one why
because this movie sucked that are this
tons of x-men but they never gave them
on our x-men origins will be because
yeah this killed it on the first try now
grant I know a lot of you were probably
expecting x-men 3 to be in here but
deadly look I don't need to say any more
there is more but I don't need to say it
Deadpool but even though I could stop
there let's continue what should have
been the easiest movie to make awesome a
standalone Wolverine movie with gambits
The Blob and actual cool-looking
Sabretooth and end up story promising
betrayal blood and vengeance turned into
a goddamn ex suckfest not only just
little to none of the continuity matchup
with the other x-men film but everything
is either boring cliched doesn't make
sense or going out of its way to piss
fans off fan favorite game it is barely
in the movie The Blob isn't a mutant he
just ate a lot that was a necessary
change good job and of course one of the
most popular and unique Marvel
characters of all time Deadpool has
pretty much no connection to his
character whatsoever the actor Ryan
Reynolds was such a Deadpool fan that he
spent years and years to get a faithful
version of the character brought to the
big screen thank you what it seems what
made people like him now still makes
people like him now
yeah you do need to do the exact goddamn
opposite of what the character was
I can't believe that didn't work
Deadpool's own film was ruthless at
mocking this movie's version of him and
rightfully so
at least with x-men 3 there was some
good
action good visual kelsey grammer sp's
interesting commentary on what should be
gone and what shouldn't this just had
nothing even the action ranges from
standard to just cartoony walking away
from my explosion haven't seen that well
give me a goddamn break
it's one of those films that should have
been handed a silver platter awesome
instead we got a dog bag puke bottom
line there's no mutant healing from this
[Music]
number seven
Blues Brothers 2000 did anybody ask for
this
anyone Blues Brothers is about as
perfect a comedy as you can get it
energized it hilarious its raunchy it's
a musical it has car chases and has some
of the most unbelievable crashes ever
caught on screen it's a friggin icon
this one this one feels like a Saturday
morning cartoon even down to having the
little kids sidekick and you want to
know why eat there because everyone else
loves all the tires unfocused slower but
not funny my god is it not funny all
that's trying to do is recapture the
magic of the first film with half the
budget half the energy and a million
subplots that clearly don't belong in
blues brother haven't you ever wanted to
see the Blues Brothers go up against a
Caribbean which fuck fuck you by
watching the first film at a simple
premise raise money to save an orphanage
hella free Stooges short could pull that
off here it's night to make clear what
they're doing it's just a band I guess
and people are chasing them down for
some reason it still doesn't give a shit
that doesn't even end it just stops it
looks like we're going to get a big
chase scene after seeing almost none
throughout the entire film and then they
roll the credits yeah
the sequel to one of the best Archie's
comedies ever and they write out all the
car chases
the one thing it has going for it is the
blues
using is actually pretty well done full
disclosure I even picked up the
soundtrack after watching it but that's
the only good connection this movie has
to the original Blues Brothers it's
pointless
it's contrived it's not humorous it's
the first film with a mission from God
then this is a flaming bag of dog shit
from hell
[Music]
number six
jaws 3d from the film that created the
summer blockbuster - the film often
deemed as a summer ballbuster
John 3d is exactly what you would think
of not only in a bad sequel but in a bad
3d see look at this shit
this is beyond embarrassing what's the
point of having a 3d so that you can see
in three dimensions how bad the keying
is granted I know the shark looks a
little fake in the first bill in the
mauryas field but nothing compares to
this one this is one of the most
laughably lame effects ever that is you
know except for all the other effects
and they aren't just bad in fact that
you had to freeze-frame to see how bad
they are they hold on these
uncomfortable illusions for a while like
they were proud of how they look one of
the funniest things is that they shoot
scenes in that obnoxious 3d way where
it'll zoom in on something for the
effect but because the film doesn't come
with glasses
you're just awkwardly looking at
close-up stuff for no reason
wow that is really not impressive no not
at all
on top of it the story's forgettable the
characters are cut out there's even a
tie-in with it taking place at SeaWorld
how would you like that advertising go
to SeaWorld where you'll die how could
such a film dripping with subtle former
suspense and drama be reduced to
something diss laughably sad just when
you thought it was safe to go back in
the water you realize it is because it
means we're sensing going to the movie
theater to see this thing
you
number five Superman for the quest for
peace it's not like the Superman movies
that had the best track record but
easily the word comes down to four maybe
a metaphor 34 little bit more with a I
guess well intended message about
stopping nuclear warfare this movie not
only had no idea how to make any strong
message about the subject apart from
stop it but it had some of the worst
writing acting and effects out of all of
them
they literally use the same clip of
Superman flying several times they say
Superman's hair can hold a ton yet it
can be cut with these who we care so
little that there's actually a scene
where a human being is just taken into
space no suit no oxygen she can just
breathe
that is a special kind of I don't give a
shit in this one Superman has to fight
nuclear man a combination of Lex Luthor
and Superman's DNA and fairly the DNA of
some fabric - so he's born with clothes
boy a CNA is quite a fashion designer
most of the film is Justin fighting the
message about nuclear warfare is
abandoned surprisingly fast the quest
for peace pretty much has no peace in it
but a hell of a lot of shit beating what
message were they even trying to get
across that bad ending your nuclear
warheads can result in a super alien
demon actually the idea of getting rid
of the warheads technically leads to our
destruction
doesn't it none of it adds up from
recycling scenes to recycling villains
to recycling literally the same footage
just follow-up is anything but suit
number four Star Wars The Phantom Menace
yeah pretty hard not to have what many
consider the most hated sequel of all
time
so I technically think Attack of the
Clones the worst movie Phantom Menace
gives much more of a letdown than really
any Star Wars viewer fan or not could
have expected going from a simple story
with strong beams likable characters and
a well-defined mythos this prequel gave
us way too much story boring flash
annoying flash racist characters and
poop jokes because that's what was
missing from Star Wars abandoning the
mix of practical effects with
superimposed imagery this world lives
mainly in the computer never really
looking like the main characters are
looking at what should be right in front
us the movie has done everything to
rewrite the ideas and simple that fans
held so dear by saying faith and
religion can be in a blood test virgin
births are totally nothing now how big
deal and people don't need to have
personalities because we can put all our
humor in one of not good character Star
Wars was loved so much that took spans
several viewings for them to accept that
this is actually a bad movie he was like
the stages of death going through denial
bargaining fear anger but when they
accepted finally said in there was no
denying what crabs dorm we all witness
this went from arguably the most
anticipated film in a lifetime to the
most despised betrayal of a fanbase felt
with a creator no matter what the future
of the Star Wars movies hold this film
is so bad that everyone can almost
guarantee it can't possibly get worse
[Music]
number three Batman and Robin
let's try to be fair Batman has been
through purposefully degrading past
lives before this is clearly trying to
be one of those silly mocking fat tires
of the superhero but that's funny I
don't see Adam West Burt Ward or MADtv
presents in fact I see the actors from
the previous serious movies that they
were making not too far back so how does
this make any goddamn bad sense nobody
wants to see a corny satire of our
beloved superhero they want to see the
superhero taken seriously this is about
the clearest example of not being taken
seriously not one iota as bad as them
and forever got it did at times at least
trying to be a real Batman film this is
a hardcore mocking of a precious icon
all the way and even with that said it's
not a very good mocking everything here
is either a diet version of the Adam
West Show we're just i spun all the
women horribly it's like if Spaceballs
what's the fifth Star Wars movie hell is
either like that cuz baseballs is funny
before like if disaster movie was the
fit Star Wars movie every second is an
insult to one of the greatest
superheroes of all time and it knows
it's doing it and doesn't care they care
so little that they even throw in you
know what the one thing the film has
going for it is like mo Schumacher films
it surprisingly looks very nice
not at all like Batman but Schumacher's
ability to show off a set as production
values is always welcome another than
that it's an unbearable experience it's
hard to say this is the worst superhero
movie made but it's easily the worst
superhero sequel made especially when
using the same actors as the same
characters from what apparently is about
to be the same serious world how on
earth would this have worked what
mindset thought this made logical sense
all I can say is fully back
number two son of the mask okay this
really shouldn't be that hard a sequel
to the mask you can't get Jim Carrey
that kid who won the Nintendo Power
contest got gypped actually you can't
and it's an interesting story looking at
this but none of that matters just find
somebody else do some cartoony effects
and it should be pepper very weak this
is anything but passable this is not
only one of the worst sequels put
together with some of the most horrific
lis nightmare inducing imagery but it
often makes a lot of people's worst
films of all time lift it's so ugly so
poorly rendered so tragically captain so
terribly written that's just thinking
back on it often triggers post-traumatic
stress disorder in most viewers it's
loud it's hideous it's not funny
it makes no sense it has some of the
worst CG in history and it's horrifying
visual still can't have us believing
that they actually called it family
bitches every moment of this film is an
endurance test asking you how much of
your senses can we assault before you
hate all humanity it's nonstop annoying
non-stop idiotic non-stop terrified this
movie is a son of something alright but
definitely ate the mask
before we get to number one a few
runners-up I'm alone three it didn't try
hard enough to be on this list but
that's also why it's an honorable
mention x-men three Wolverine is worse
but killing off a ton of your characters
adding up to nothing is a good way to
piss off a fanbase spider-man 3 stupid
yes but the other films are stupid too
this one just took that one's empty
Terminator Genisys so the other films
are totally retcon now huh whatever
everybody's already forgotten you the
Pirates of the Caribbean sequels not
being so needlessly long and complicated
you're a pirate's movie Matt Lawrence of
Arabia
course - because course always needed a
bigger budget for bigger stars and dance
numbers really captured the spirit of
the original there Highlander - the
first one ended fine like you've been
right or it's a chance to muck it all up
die hard 5 want to hate John McClane
now you can for one easy step of
watching this shithole Mortal Kombat
annihilation
we knew nobody liked Mortal Kombat 4 the
gore so we took that all out giving you
the B movie story and crappy characters
that made it popular to begin with
you're welcome
Tyron alright let's get to it the number
one worst movie sequel of all time is
troll 2 I mean how can it not be this is
not only considered the worst sequel
ever made this is often considered the
worst film ever made it does everything
a horrible sequel is supposed to do it
has awful acting awful writing awful
effects and of course has nothing to do
with the first troll movie literally
nothing there is no connection the fact
that I even technically troll their
Goblin spell backwards this is such a
bad movie that they actually make good
movies on what a bad movie it is there
are documentaries studying this film
it's something of a Marvel now the catch
is it is very similar to the room in one
of those it's so bad it's good thing it
is hilariously awful and incredibly
entertaining
which could have some people debating
whether or not it should be number one
but that's not what we're judging we are
judging work and if a movie even by the
people who acted in it call it the worst
film ever made I think it's probably the
worst sequel to it's a film so bad it
goes into that realm of being positive a
movie that brings a smile to your face a
perfect anomaly its choices are not only
dumb they're mentally challenging how
could anyone be okay with the decisions
made how did anyone say yes that'll do
under the magazine it's an amazing film
so bad that it truly has to be seen to
be believed
it's been talked about so much it enters
the realm of legend everybody who knows
that film knows this movie and anyone
who knows bad sequels have to be
reminded of it because they forget it
even in the sequel it has that little to
do with the first even though they're
the two in the title it gets absolutely
everything wrong it just so happens to
get them wrong in all the right way it's
a blunder so big that everybody needs to
see it when somebody says this is the
worst of the worst it's hard not to turn
to them and say yep I can't argue with
that
are there any that we missed well leave
them in the comments below and by God
tell us how you survived them I'm a
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to
[Music]
you
ah
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
brain and behavioral research foundation
since 1987 this foundation has awarded
more than 346 million dollars in grants
more than 4,000 scientists around the
world
their mission alleviating the suffering
caused by mental illness that will lead
to advances and breakthroughs in
scientific research 100 percent of all
donor contributions for research are
invested in grants leading to
discoveries in understanding causes and
improving treatments of disorders in
children and adults many of those
conditions are depression bipolar
disorder schizophrenia autism and
anxiety disorders like
obsessive-compulsive and post-traumatic
stress disorder if you look at their
site and their YouTube page you can see
all the various places around the world
and all the good people they try to help
mental health is crucial to a healthy
life and these people know definitely
take a look at their wonderful
organization and see how you as well can
help them make the mind as strong as
possible
you
[Music]